there's no time
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey okay we are back it worked
technically we had some technical
difficulties
what else is new i'm looking at the chat
live chat
and it's sucking way behind what you
have
everybody's in there yeah 26.
not even a crash but it's this [ __ ]
computer it's like i don't do anything
with it all day this is our dedicated
streaming laptop i don't
keep a lot of [ __ ] on here i don't you
know what i mean just so i
it's not gummed up with a bunch of crap
it seems like every now and then it's
like oh i'm totally fine all day and
then like five minutes before we start
streaming it's like oh
and then it shuts the bed yeah and um
just to make me angry
i guess today i gotta i'm coming down
with a cold started coming out of the
cold yesterday from the flu season
hopefully you don't have the rona my
sharona my corona
yeah you're about you're about 10 months
too late on that parody song
that came out like the day after the
[ __ ] they first announced the virus
i wasn't paying attention i wasn't
paying attention
yeah well you know i'm just saying okay
maria says technology can't live with it
can't shoot it yeah right
that's what i'm saying yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
crashing oh my god damn time
uh somebody in the last stream said yeah
we've done
cults three weeks in a row it wasn't
really it wasn't really my intention but
those were the ones because like i said
if you don't know um i let the patrons
vote
like i usually put up five or six
options
every week and let the patrons vote on
what they want to see on the next show
and it just so happened that the last
three weeks the winning thing was cults
because i guess we haven't covered a
[ __ ] ton of cults in the past so maybe
people are like you know wanting us to
catch up on that kind of [ __ ]
put my head on it gives me more
authority
i thought yeah i thought you said that
you only needed that
give me more authority yes sandra says
don't infect jenny she has no health
insurance right i'll just kind of have
to
i told him earlier i was just like don't
breathe on pokey either
i don't want her getting sick i already
i think i already had that coronavirus
you might have but i don't really know
and it was about a week before they even
told anybody about it
and then and then uh kadavatsan
around that time i was sick his dad was
sick in mexico and unfortunately died
and the hospital down there said that it
wasn't
it was a unusual flu
it's an eighth an eight an atypical flu
they didn't ever see anything like it
i think i think [ __ ] corona was here
weeks before they told him
before people knew well during that time
remember i had that weird cold yeah you
did it was a weird cold
um i didn't get it but i it felt very
strange
i don't think i've ever gotten a flu in
my whole entire life i think it was that
i'm you know it was it was just a real
dry
feeling and it uh
you felt sick but it didn't really have
real strong symptoms
yeah you just felt like you didn't want
to do anything like really i've had a
couple of colds like that
where it was just mostly just like a dry
hack yeah i don't like i said
i don't think i was trying to think of
it earlier today because when we were
joking earlier about you having the rona
um i was trying to think i was like have
i actually ever in
all my 48 years have i ever had the flu
i don't think i have
you might be immune to that not that i
can remember i mean i might have had it
a really long time ago i don't think
i've ever been
so sick with like a cold or a flu that i
couldn't like get out of bed or go to
work or whatever
yeah i've been taking vitamin t that's
going vitamin c zinc and [ __ ] alcohol
so hell yeah
well alcohol that's the nice thing about
having a lot of alcohol other than it
kind of making you feel crappy the next
day but
it does actually make you feel a lot
better yeah the night of like when you
drink a lot of it
yeah i think it does
because that's usually the only even
when i get colds because i don't usually
even get a lot of colds i get one like
every two years or something
and even when i get a cold it's usually
super super mild
and the only thing that i get is like a
little bit of a runny nose and i just
get like a dry
hacking cough that kind of hangs around
for a week or two which is just more
annoying than anything else
like i usually have to go through a
whole big [ __ ] bag of
cough drops because i can't sleep
without like waking up and hacking and
stuff but i don't feel sick otherwise
but that's really like the only thing i
get i mean you know
as not wood as my grandmother used to
say even though i don't think this is
really what
not particle board whatever
but yeah so you know what are you gonna
do
um yeah maria was saying very possible
the virus was here before we knew it my
mother came home from oregon with some
kind of flu it was really sick
she got that was february yeah well i
mean it stands to reason it's like if
they
because they don't really know you know
when when they get here and it's like
and
when the you know virus gets here and it
had like enough of a
footprint that they actually started to
notice it i'm sure that it had been here
for a little while and
yes you know it was just so spread out
that they didn't really notice it and
i'll tell you what
all right i'm not gonna say it was done
on purpose not gonna say that it was any
conspiracy theory or anything
because it wasn't but a bottom don't you
don't jump in
and piss on my parade before i [ __ ]
tell my god
oh you're a you're old goddamn story
he's only allowed to do that to me about
a week
before i got sick i went to [ __ ]
wally world
to go get some rotel and some of that
velveeta cheese because that was it
worth it because
i was having a white trash flashback
it was just it was taking me back that's
another shirt white trash
bag why are you guys always making that
okay i can see you guys making sure it's
out of what i should
say i was having that damn i was having
a relapse
the mississippi relapse i had to [ __ ]
get some of the old-fashioned
[ __ ] cheddar cheese dip well yeah
that was there like that dip all right
guess who showed up
an entire bus of [ __ ] chinese
students got all men all boys
and a man i'm just not going to say that
maybe they had it
you know what i mean because it's
possible just saying you know
woohound you know i mean the thing is
maybe they
sent them to [ __ ] to [ __ ] wally
world state
why would they send us to them why would
they send them to that particular woman
because
because of the people of walmart man
they would be great vectors
you see in biological warfare yeah
and biological [ __ ] walmart
yeah you see in biological warfare they
had [ __ ] boats
filled with [ __ ] infected cockroaches
or infected bats and rats and [ __ ]
and you drop them overseas and they let
them go as vectors and [ __ ] [ __ ] wally
world would be the
goddamn the same exact thing if you
spread that [ __ ] just touch that [ __ ]
everywhere you know
although to be honest with you it's like
that's probably not even the worst [ __ ]
you can get from going
and that's like not even done on purpose
i try to never go to walmart
there's something really really
depressing
about walmart i think we've talked about
this before and it's not just
like the [ __ ] weird-ass people that
are in there i mean although that's part
of it i'm sure
but i don't know if it's just something
to do with the layout or the lighting
or i don't know what it is it's like
every time i walk i go in there i'm just
like man i'd really like to
kill myself it's like going back to
mississippi it's terrible and it's like
i've even been in ones like in nice
areas like in nice neighborhoods and
stuff and they all have that same
feeling to them well they're cheap yeah
but target's cheap too and it doesn't
feel like that
it's just like okay i'm not gonna it's
it's about retail
originally walmart what was so good it
was all in one location and and it was
real no frills
no fur it was like a [ __ ] big
warehouse that you went to
and i remember it like back in the 80s
going to it yeah they first kind of knew
they were cool it was like buying
something direct it wasn't like buying
retail
kind of like sam's which it's related
they own sales
so but eventually that became retail
eventually that became the modern
version of kmart
yeah if you go look on videos go go look
on
youtube and look at the final days of
kmart people went in there to document
it
kmart had not been updated really since
the 70s and the 80s and some
kmart is kind of depressing too it was
real depressing it looked like something
out of damn old soviet union
a lot of people were like what the hell
are you talking about it says yeah man
the 80s
you didn't think of it at the time but
looking back on it it had a soviet look
because everything looked like crap
yeah real cheap especially in [ __ ] we
couldn't even
like we had to shop at kmart sometimes
but [ __ ] we were shopping at like
[ __ ]
pick and save yeah that's how [ __ ]
broke dick we were
yeah way the future's gonna is like
target now
target up the game or targets yeah my
mom calls it that too yes
fancy that's fancy walmart hey man some
of their like food brands and [ __ ] like
that are really really good
like i like some of the target brand
candy and all that kind of stuff that's
the end of
malls malls are going away a lot of
stuff's going away
gonna go back to the damn kind of like
strip malls open air malls
and big box stores kind of like target
but you know you have to have a good
environment for people want to go over
there and go in it that's what i mean
you know i mean walmart is so
i don't know what it is i would rather
go to big lots
than go to walmart and big lots is kind
of depressing too walmart's kind of
depressing but
that's where you go to buy a television
that's where you go to buy [ __ ] like
[ __ ] velveeta cheese
it's where you go to buy a rotel that's
where you go to buy spam
they can get a whole case of spam and
people like why the [ __ ] would you want
to buy spam
in florida you might have be a good idea
to buy a couple cases of spam well he
just wants to have spam so he can eat it
all the time
i like spam but you like spam you know
if you have a hurricane here you might
be eating spam
for a [ __ ] couple weeks before the
power comes back on spam and granola
spam and granola bars
well yeah it's like actually you know
what we didn't really uh we had some
hurricanes this year but none of them
came real that close to us which is nice
but you know it'll be uh june 1st again
we start all over june 1st to november
30th
you got to watch out with september and
october being the worst
got to watch out for them hurricanes
[ __ ] power be out for two weeks
yeah [ __ ] road flooded and whatnot we
got a lot of people in here [ __ ]
florida yeah that's how i always say it
do we uh have anything that we got to
talk about before we start the show
i can't remember if i shouted out that
we have a new patron
in the uk named gwen i thought that i
had shouted out before but i
didn't but i don't remember and i had it
written in my waco notes
because i make a you know make a little
thing with little shout outs at the top
for every episode
and then i was like wait a minute i
thought i already said because it was
quite a while ago
but i guess i didn't because it's still
in my notes and i probably would have
taken it out if i had so hey gwen
nice to see you yeah over there in the
uk
yeah some people are talking about
amazon one thing that i do like
amazon for i order a lot of [ __ ] from
amazon like books and stuff
is that um that little uh delivery thing
they do where you can just like go month
to month or whatever
and i get all kind of like i get shampoo
conditioner
body wash like [ __ ] that i buy all the
time
you know what i mean like lipstick [ __ ]
like [ __ ] [ __ ] like that
and you can get them like to send it
automatically like every
however every month or every couple
weeks every month every six months every
four months you can pretty much do
whatever you want
so future of shopping well it's cheap
and it's like so much easier so it's
like now i have like right here like
right underneath you can't see this
but i have a huge stockpile like there's
[ __ ] body wash and there's like
[ __ ] conditioner under there
and i have some in there and i have some
under the sink so we're never gonna run
out of [ __ ] body wash [ __ ]
it's like they just
they send it every three weeks i think
because i go through a lot of body wash
i'm just saying business says he got his
fleshlight off amazon
ain't that some [ __ ] yeah you can buy i
used to i used to actually sell sex toys
on amazon
yeah that worked for a while until they
did until they
start putting you at the bottom of the
search list you have to be new to be at
the top of the search list
yeah yeah i mean i almost made a
thousand dollars a month doing that yeah
for
for a little while for a couple but then
like so many new ones like flooded the
market and then it was just like wasn't
there anymore
yeah it's a good side gig for a little
bit yeah i mean that was changing fast
during that time
people bought some weird [ __ ] yeah
and it was kind of like drop shipping
you didn't really front any of the
[ __ ]
yeah i didn't have any of this stuff
here i just had a wholesaler because i
had a wholesaler
number you know what i mean so you just
yeah you just go to like a sex
toy wholesaler place and they're like
hey this person ordered this and they
just sent it so i didn't have any stock
here or anything like that
but yeah it worked out pretty good i
don't you know like i said i thought it
was really interesting like the [ __ ]
that people would buy
it was mostly like weird [ __ ] like you
know
like sounding yeah because it's hard to
find
you guys know what that is but just
google that
you might not want it google
google penelope black diamond
sounding it's like this 120 pound
[ __ ] super skinny german golf girl
with
implants each one of the size of damn
basketball
and she [ __ ] takes a [ __ ]
stainless steel
rod and sticks it down her [ __ ]
boyfriend's [ __ ] dick it's just and
your urethra
and it's like a whole kit i can't
understand that i sold a few of those
i can't understand that some people are
into that how does he how does he take
that
well the pain is the pain and the
discomfort is
the issue oh come on it's so fun it's so
fun when you get all uncomfortable he's
going to start like crossing his legs
yeah he's going to be like i'm not even
going to be on the show
you know but yeah um so what are we
talking about okay so yeah
gwen is our newest uh person newest
patron
tanner says ah yeah
yeah it's uh you know i'm you know i'm
not shaming no shame
just as long as you're not hurting
anybody else it's not my thing yeah
she's going to it like she's some kind
of doctor or something you know and
[ __ ] he's filming it well you got to
be real
careful when you're doing that guys i
call it filming it they don't film
anything anymore look i'm recording it
well yeah but what the hell else yeah
they were selling that [ __ ] online
yeah through their own website and [ __ ]
[ __ ] but it [ __ ] leaks out and
it's just like
i get all kinds of people sending me
weird [ __ ] you know
well now you're really gonna get people
sending you
don't be surprised if you get a sounding
kit in them
mexico is really good for uh sending me
photographs of [ __ ] like amazing
[ __ ] booties
and gigantic boobs and stuff you know
mexico's [ __ ]
really trying to break records right now
you know
and they're they're mostly instagram
girls yeah but it's just funny man dudes
are like
like hey check that out and you're like
oh you know it's just
in messenger like trading baseball yeah
yeah
that's kind of oxlon he's like what do
you think of that
they're like oh man oh and it's just
like it's like psychological warfare
dudes can't help but share that [ __ ] i
guess
i'm going to show you something you know
oh man you got me
this does kind of that does kind of make
me laugh yeah
well back in the day they were probably
[ __ ] trading [ __ ] clips from
[ __ ] football and [ __ ]
basketball clothes now they're like nah
porn look at that
porn is the [ __ ] sports of the future
one of the one of my favorite porn
things that we discovered was i like
that fetish where
the women in high heels step on those
dude's scrotes yeah you know what i mean
like you stick your balls like up
through a
little hole see she's into some weird
[ __ ] man she'll [ __ ] that's well
that's really funny it's just funny to
me
it's not particularly arousing it's just
yeah and also kicking dudes in the
[ __ ] nuts as hard as they can she's
got [ __ ] high heels going boom
and the guy goes oh that's just like
really really i can't understand how
dude could just and he's just bracing
himself
that's just like damn these
[ __ ] are crazy well some of
those ones that we saw like with the
women with the heels and they were just
like like i said the dudes would put
them
yeah they put their balls like up
through a hole like in a glass box or
whatever because he's like underneath it
and they're just there's like squash and
why i'm like holy crap
how do they not and i'm just like
fascinated i'm like how do they not
[ __ ]
just splatter everywhere i have like a
weird face and then have this cruel
streak in them
you know oh big time i'm not denying
that i had this cruel streak
i'm not denying that we're we're way
more i'm just you know
we're not psychos necessarily but some
of the [ __ ] that we think of
i think is way way more [ __ ] up than
what dudes think of we just keep it to
ourselves most of the time
you know what i mean and i will say this
too and this is um
like a book i'm going to be reviewing in
a couple of weeks most of the
um real real [ __ ] up horror books that
i've read
have been have been written by women
yeah real [ __ ] up [ __ ]
i mean some of the dudes are they're
real graphic and everything i'm just
like yeah okay that's fine but
what some of the ones with like the
really really [ __ ] up
um like psychological [ __ ] or like some
[ __ ] that people like oh my god no like
a dude would never think of that
because that's like this the cruelest
thing ever
no t she was kicking him with uh those
damn
like six inch heel platform stripper
shoes
they're like red ones yeah yeah yeah
stripper shoes
stripper boots it's been a long time
since you watched that but
i still remember that the [ __ ] metal
the metal [ __ ] platform or not metal
but the wooden platform i think it
wouldn't
they're probably plastic though but the
the platform probably about four inches
thick they look like it weighed a lot
and she's
boom kicking this dude he was tied up
going
and i was just like this is [ __ ]
insane is that dude you're gonna be able
to have kids after that and she was
getting thinking she was getting him
good and then i was thinking i was like
how can i get paid to just
kick dudes in the balls all day because
i would totally take that job yeah
yeah just tie him up right there and
also kick the [ __ ] out of your balls man
he was kind of like one of those pitiful
he's like a pitiful
you know what do they call them just
kind of like a sub although you know
what's weird though i feel like and i
don't know if this is still true
but what i know of you know the bdsm
community they usually say that dudes
that are real
into being like humiliated in that way
like hey lick a toilet or whatever
they're usually real high-powered dudes
yeah because they're so used to like in
their day-to-day life they're always in
control of everything so they kind of
get off on not having
control and having somebody else like
[ __ ] with them now tila goes tom could
you stand for getting kicked in the
balls like that for a billion and i'm
gonna say i tell you what
t i'm gonna grip my teeth and you're
gonna kick me in the balls i'm gonna
make that [ __ ] billion dollars you're
[ __ ] right i'll just have that like
that dog
i i would go through a lot of [ __ ] for a
billion dollars
[ __ ] biting on a piece of [ __ ]
leather or something
but you know
she must have kicked that dude about 15
times yeah she was having a great time
yeah it's [ __ ] like i said that must
be like the best job in the world and it
looked real
just kicking i think [ __ ] well they
kind of went into that one remember we
reviewed the uh the movie mope which was
based on a true story
that was kind of uh those two dudes
that's kind of how they so
well after they kind of got started like
cleaning up porn sets which is like the
the low to the low but then after that
they got put in the porn
where the women were kicking them in the
balls all this and that was like the
just the next wrong
somebody said cleaning somebody sent me
that video because it had been edited
into a into a little video you could
share on messenger
all right she kicks him in the balls and
he goes ah
and then it clips in thank you victor
thank you very much vic and then it
[ __ ] immediately goes into your
and it final that same note it was kind
of like he was [ __ ]
singing final countdown final countdown
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
how did we even start talking about this
oh so we were talking about amazon and
they were talking about weird sex toys
as we said because i did used to sell
sex stories on amazon a long time ago
no no one's giving us money man you're
the first one
so thank you i'm gonna slide cold
you're gonna die so i'm uh trying to put
on some extra alcohol
yeah and uh it has a cough suppressant
now last week we did our uh
was a three hour stream almost four hour
stream just
and i don't know if the show was good i
don't remember a whole lot
that's what makes it fun jenny was
really [ __ ] up at the end
she's like uh talking in circles and i'm
like okay we're gonna have to end it
and you're like yeah we're gonna end it
and then we had it i think we ended the
show about four times
probably that sounds like [ __ ] i would
yeah
yeah i think it was good i don't know i
think i'm gonna try to i mean i couldn't
have been that far gone because i did
remember to post it on instagram and
everything was spelled correctly
so i couldn't have been that drunk i
think uh
i think what we're gonna do is i'm gonna
i'm gonna have like a very
um skeletonized outline of certain
things we can talk about
maybe like uh certain cases paranormal
cases well just you know like a quick
outline
yeah so if there's ever any kind of
like lull in it or if we start going
along some stupid path we can at least
use that to get us back on track oh
everybody loves us going along stupid
paths though
i don't know i just we're gonna let them
[ __ ] decide i'm gonna say like
tomorrow
or sunday matinee we're gonna talk about
that surviving death
series on netflix so i think that'll
bring up all kinds of fascinating topics
because i have some
i have some thoughts about that
so i think that'll be fun too do you
want to talk about waco
let's go ahead and talk about waco
they're talking about it
about albert fish getting kicked in the
[ __ ] nuts
yeah he was into that wasn't it yeah
louis hernandez he said louis said that
he passed out before the show was over
well that makes me feel yeah we were up
early last night yeah
guys you were up early look fine because
yeah we can shake it off quick
like i said man three aspirins and a
whole thing of water before you go to
sleep malachi says we should put in time
steps no
dude putting timestamps in there that's
just more work
and there's no rhyme or reason to have
that [ __ ] we're talking about
the time stamps wouldn't help they
probably wouldn't because i feel like we
start talking about the case and then we
start talking about other [ __ ] and then
we go back and talk about the case
and then we start talking about other
[ __ ] again so it's just kind of like i'd
put i have to put like 50 bajillion time
stamps in there
i'm just like just just roll with it
just go with the flow
man you know what i'm saying well
alcohol starts taking hold sometimes and
i get sidetracked yeah because i don't
know
something something said and that
something said in the chat or something
i say like she said send you offline
yeah on some direction but that's kind
of the nature of this show this isn't
you know that's just the way it is yeah
it's a free form
form show kind of like an old school
radio show it's amorphous
yeah it's not just any one thing i mean
it's you know we do have like a topic on
these ones but
and we do i do actually try to
i mean i actually do do a lot of
research on these some of which just
goes out the window when i get drunk and
i can't remember what i was talking
about
but and i do try to get as much in there
as i wanted to because sometimes like
afterward i'll wake up and i'll be like
oh [ __ ] i forgot to mention
xyz or whatever like i'll forget to
mention a couple of facts
but louis said he's trying to match his
drink for trig he couldn't handle it
yeah well we're um we're old
school alcoholics we're not
alcoholics we don't like i said an
alcoholic is somebody that just has to
drink all the time and they can't
we don't oh no no no no no no no no
no uh oh no
really oh man again
why is this keep doing this yeah look
they still see you
it's just ours